so I'm will smoke I run sustainability
for Intel and the question I want to
address is dealing with the economy
versus dealing with the environment and
my simple message in return is we should
never let this crisis go to waste as at
the personal level here are things we
can do we can do to less two less
degrees of heat to less degrees of
cooling to less contracts a week we can
do one less one less me love me two
reasons one more conservation effort or
weeding and there's one more thing we
can do more on which is really think
through how we get with recycling and
think through how we deal with an energy
are now at the big level at the
collective level there are issues that
we have to go deal with we have to deal
with the economics of the two places in
the world that can absorb carbon dioxide
which is the ocean and the rain for
screen we don't really have either of
those work out today and we need to
change the language the way we describe
energy sources they're not alternative
energy sources there is sustainable
energy source this may sound simplistic
but the fact of the matter is if each
individual can make the kind of changes
we're talking about and help their
collective make the macro arguments that
we talked about the world would be a
better place